[Music]
meeting and to clear the meeting open
are we any apologies
recording in progress
right
no
no apologies
any conflicts of interest yeah i've got
one any of the
discussions about
disposing of the masonic property or
buying more properties for freemasons i
want to stand aside for that because i'm
still amazing
all right thank you murray uh item 6.3
uh has been withdrawn it'll be coming
back next next month for your
information
that that was about um
bus stop extensions and ashley street
which paul knows a little bit about
right
conflicts of interest
no conflicts of interest welcome andy
we'll see you there morris is coming
all right uh the minutes have been
circulated are there any corrections
alterations
the p appear to be none so someone
prepared to move that we confirm them
only that now second paul and duncan
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye contrary
carried
any matters arising
yes mr chair
and there was going to be a follow-up
about um
a potential bilingual name for the
milton reserve
i just wondered when that would come
back to the board
kay's not here she was in touch with
that area so
tia if you make a note of that uh we'll
we'll notify the board when we
have a response thanks i will say just a
question that are we actually involving
manufenua in the project as well um in
terms of native plants and so on i just
didn't see anything in the report about
that so that might tie in also with the
naming
okay
right
moving on
uh item 6.1 township lighting concepts
pages 17 to 46
vanessa welcome vanessa
thank you good evening mr chair and um
board members so the purpose of this
report is really just to seek board
member endorsement of the town center
feature lighting designs for rengura
the designs were prepared by kevin
cawley so he's from total lighting
limited and he was selected by the town
centre feature lighting working group as
the preferred design consultant to
prepare these plans
concepts are really just intended to
guide future decisions around
lighting from a design and budgeting
perspective and also to provide some
guidance to property owners and
businesses when they're upgrading their
sites in terms of lighting
you'll note that probably the budgets
are out of date now and they'll be
subject to review when we do get to the
point of progressing the lighting in the
town centres as
part of the budget time frame that's
listed in the report so happy to take
any questions
vanessa that committee
i think andy's our rep on it but it
hasn't met for a couple of years or so
has it uh we've had i think um i haven't
been involved to be honest um only
recently i got involved in this project
so i'm not too sure exactly when the
last meeting was i believe a couple were
scheduled but then they were cancelled
just due to covert so the intention is
probably to set up another one once
we've got approval from the community
boards on the designs to start
progressing things in the background
so you'll bring that committee back
together yes yeah we will yeah i think
andy you're our rep on that from
what i understand yeah that's correct
jim
all right thank you
all right
any questions of vanessa
or
yes vanessa um
his um kevin crawley got a rough budget
because we we've actually had another
consultant at one stage and um
when we had a look at what he wanted it
was um
millions and millions of dollars to do
what he wanted to do so
i wouldn't like to um
spend a lot of money on the consultant
and find out
um he's well over
um what we're actually thinking of a
budget for that area yeah
so it's in the report in terms of actual
hardware he's put some costings there
and and section 6.1 of the report so
you'll see that for rangura the costings
or based on his design which is your
sort of street lights those sort of
pedestrian heritage looking lights that
we've got along high street and under
veranda lights he's put it at just over
a million dollars and you'll note the
budget that we've actually been
improving the long term plan is 750 so
there is a shortfall for that and that's
not including kevin's fees plus i
believe cabling was put in the street um
a few years ago when they did some town
center work but there will be other
costings around that i should note that
obviously his designs are based on you
know an aspirational outcome and there
may be aspects of those that could be
um taken out of that plan or you could
sort of pick or choose from a suite of
options if there is a desire to keep
within the budget so um yeah that is
something to consider as we progress
okay
any other questions
if not we've got a recommendation in
front of us
someone prepared to move
something
murray
moved by
murray do you wish to speak to it
i didn't actually mean to move it
something went wrong here oh well would
you happy to move it yeah yeah okay
yeah yeah
right any anyone wish to andy do you
wish that anything
um
i was really impressed with kevin um i
thought um
he was uh really passionate about what
he was doing his um
i think his design is actually probably
quite reasonable in terms of his budget
so
um yeah i'm really excited about this
happening hopefully in the future at
some stage
i hope that uh when israel
the board's experience with lights in
the high street has been a
sad affair so i hope this one goes
better yeah
any other members wish to say anything
that was my thought too john exactly as
you said
just with the lighting in the main
street it's been a lot of issues
um i've met kevin crowley and listened
to him as part of the lighting committee
and i'm very impressed with him i think
he does a great job he's a um
he gets great results i think for the
best value in my view so not that i'm an
electrician or anything like that but i
was very impressed with him we chose him
and we've had lots of talks with him and
i really like what he what he what he
comes up with i think it's it's
brilliant
all right thank you
any other speakers uh yes i'd like to
say a few words um obviously it's very
important we do get this right and and
if there are any warning signs that
we're heading down the track like we did
last time we really need to know pretty
promptly um i do feel that perhaps the
board war the last issue
members of public did contact board
members
that perhaps about the lack of action or
this very slow process so i think from
the board's perspective uh we
really need to be quite firm that we
you know we need some progress and we
need some indicators if it's not going
well
thank you duncan
all right
monique
this is going to say
can the foundation of the lighting
that's there now be of any use to the
new the new word or is it all going to
get thrown
i guess i think the underground
trenching they put cabling in to enable
capacity upgrades in the future so we
the cabling may already be at an
appropriate level to support the designs
uh the heritage poles i believe
all that sort of look will stay it's
just probably upgrading some of the
lamps you'll note that there is a focus
on 2700k lighting which is um a sort of
move in the lighting space towards that
illumination now which is actually
better for pedestrians and it's a nice
sort of softer warm glow that still
illuminates things appropriately but it
just um also is better for highlighting
town center features so that will be a
change here
but i'm not in terms of the um street
lights i i'm not too sure what the level
is there i know kai boys are sitting at
4 000 k
um south of the bridge down to hilton
street so
um yeah i'm i'm not too sure if whether
gringo high street has the same but we'd
be looking to replace those the street
lamps with 3 000.
yeah um
being an electrician i think um you'll
find that the only deducting has been
put in for the cabling but the cable is
not actually in there yet so there's
quite a big cost of cables to go in
there
okay
anyone else
murray do you want to exercise you're
unwilling and write a reply
yes well that was a bit unusual i didn't
really mean to do that
everything fell off the table here
anyway i would say that uh i would
support duncan's comments because i got
a terrible air matching from keith
getting away from the last lot
sorry about that i keep getting these
signals on here about a virus program
which i don't want
yeah and i think it causes endless
trouble there for a while and keith got
very upset about it and seemed to talk
to everybody else in the town about it
so i think the idea that duncan's got is
quite good we should actually keep
pretty tight control on the contract of
the strong
all right i'll put that all those in
favor please say aye
contrary carried
not that i can hear anything much from
here
item 6.2 pages
47-51 that's the time request for time
restriction by the murrah school
shane i think you're yes
there somewhere there we are
good evening um just i'll take the the
report is read just a quick bit of
context this came up in conversations
with the school in preparation for the
sewer construction works that are
presently going on around the school
proximity and that led them to put in a
request for us to
help address a long-standing issue
apparently with parents um as it's not
uncommon at school time double parking
around both gates to the school and so
in conversations with the school we're
really hoping to try to get
more vehicular based pickups off of
church street which is what the parking
restrictions would be aimed towards and
the king street gate would be oriented
more towards uh children who are walking
to school or cycling so there's a little
bit of a modal separation there
thank you any questions of shown kirsten
shane just um wondering why the board is
involved so late in these conversations
um
obviously we can provide some of the
community feedback and i don't have a
problem with this particular report but
what i'm saying is wouldn't it be better
to come to the board to have a quick
discussion about what you're planning to
do before we basically get presented
with a fader complete
i certainly could reach out further i
guess
um i will admit on my part i do rely a
little bit when i am in a case like this
on a bit of background and context for
the schools so when i am unaware of a
circumstance that has
um a little bit more of a of a focus or
that i'm aware of their outstanding
background issues i do tend to do a bit
more outreach i was under the impression
i was not in the impression that there
were any other
um
contextual issues to be concerned with
on on this one so that may have been a
message i guess we were you aware
obviously this is dudley park this is
the swimming pool this is the netball
courts this is a whole lot of things and
and there's residents obviously in the
street as well so i just wonder whether
would would it be possible in the future
to perhaps come to the board for a
general context as well as going to the
actual person concerned
yeah and i also want to balance we get
lots of parking report requests and some
that do make it through to action and i
certainly don't want to be taking up all
of your time with that but certainly can
try to reach out more
thank you and kirsten that's one of the
reasons the point you raise why 6.3 has
been deferred so shane can come and talk
to the board just exactly yep thank you
mr chair
dude right
you've got the recommend any other
questions
happy to move mr chair
by kirsten segment bye
i'll second box monique kirsten do you
wish to speak
absolutely um thank you very much to
staff for working with the school on
this and and the only feedback i've had
is actually that this is desperately
needed so um it would that's the
response you would have got from the
board if you'd come to us um
we obviously got to just be aware of
parking when it comes to any of these
sort of p5 restrictions but as it's been
limited to school times that actually
makes it better for people who are using
that area church street's a very very
busy street um very with a multitude of
activities
and so therefore we need to consider all
the residents and all the people who use
that area uh when we're looking at any
sort of parking restrictions but i
really i think that the staff have got
it completely right here and this will
help the community and it may make
things a lot easier for the parents
thanks thank you chris monique do you
wish to speak yeah i think it seems a
perfectly logical solution perhaps to
the problems there so great
no questions
do any other speakers
appear to be none so there's nothing to
reply to so i'll put that all those in
favor please say aye
contrary carried or i should say signal
sorry yeah yeah i'm getting there
5.6.4 request for
parking five restrictions outside the
post shop pages 58-61 it's a report for
your information as much as anything but
shane do you wish to
add anything
just uh that i was our recommendation
that the existing supply is working
relatively well but certainly would be
um appreciative of any further feedback
on this but any questions to shane on
that
it's a difficult spot i acknowledge that
monique
i think i think i may be the one who
initially raised the problem that
someone had suggested it to me he was a
disabled person i see now the post
office has automatic doors at the back
previously the issue was people couldn't
get in the back door because of the
really heavy door to open but now it's
got an automatic door there and the
disability parts right there as well so
i think it probably it's not going to be
such an issue perhaps in the future you
raised an important point when they
clear the post shop about six months or
five months ago changed the doors and
upgraded that for handicapped people and
that's huge improvement yeah right any
other questions or comments
uh my only comment would be that shane
it was a very logical report and i think
if you read the process i think the
conclusion you come to is a very fair
one
thank you duncan
right
so mr we are moving the report
give me a moment we're just kidding
has someone prepared to move the report
moved by monique seconded by duncan
do you wish to speak to it monique
no duncan no i think i have thank you he
thinks he has right i'll put that all
out i'll mr chair just quickly if i may
um again very very important to talk to
the businesses in that area before we've
made any decisions but i think the right
decision has been made with that
correction to the door thank you thank
you right anyone else
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye the country carried
road naming item 6.5 263 bark has rode
pages 62 to
scott are you there
who's introducing this from the staff
no one
okay well so if you have a look at the
report on page 62
just
the report itself is quite
straightforward but you should note
uh
in the policy for area for example
uh no
no road can be a name or similar name
now to any other in the district and of
course there is a port points out there
is a fox uh
lane or something road somewhere down
near waikoku or someone said the fox
name already exists
in in the district so it's quite
important to note to note that so
right
let's see if there's any any questions
or someone i know there's been some
discussion amongst several members on
this and i
thank andy for bringing the difficulties
with the proposed name to to my
awareness and
i know you've been talking to other
members so look with any questions you
want
want to know if we can answer between us
first can i i don't take a comment at
the stage or no no we'll get a motion
and then we're just questions just
questions monique just a question i've i
looked up the map i thought it said tua
hiwi and then and they wrote in the name
was cox cox road cox
is that the name that they're saying is
the same
well the staff person's not here but in
the report he says there is a name for
the road
is similar to an existing road name and
kayak week
so i can't argue with that we've got
those type persons so but
irrespective of that i think the board
will make a decision that
is appropriate mr chairman uh
to further things if we were to uh find
favor with another name would we move an
amendment to the
no no there's no need to move an
amendment you would simply move receive
the report that proves the following
whatever name okay okay
i would ask that we removed the report
and we approved the name richmond lane
and we're second
to that
do i need to give the reason before and
nc notes no no a bit of sicker mr chair
okay
duncan up to you okay um the name um
well why are some have something for
subdividers and they do what capital at
risk um
considering the duplication of the name
fox in the district i believe it's
unacceptable given the rich history of
waimakariri i believe the issue of
richmond
lane is appropriate and mr joseph barker
took up land on barkers road um on the
25th of
he named his farm
richmond hill so i believe richmond lane
is quite acceptable within the area that
is
also mr barker also donated two acres
which it now stands the logan school
so the history is very solid there
and considering that perhaps
that the time that bhagavan has been
involved
is right and this is not the first time
an advisory group a group that i have
been involved with had issues with names
proposed by developers is against taking
the background of the people for a
paisley road on the peshdale rail trail
was another example where
my far more suitable name was found so i
believe richmond lane
is the there's a very positive
linking our history
within the district
right thank you kirsten
yes i also having been made aware of the
history i felt it was a lovely tie-in of
a sub division that's coming off barkers
road uh to use the name of the farm that
was original so i'm highly supportive of
this recommendation
thank you just speaking very briefly i
totally support it i think it's a good
example
of those in the area that know the
history of the area as board members
working well to get a good outcome
so let's take some any any other
speakers
do you wish to exercise right to play
duncan other i think the ones who who
contributed to
the wider decision making it uh when i
first read it yes i was quite concerned
but i think we've come to a very good
conclusion
thank you i'll put that all those in
favor please say aye aye aye
show hands whatever
old habits die hard
item 6.6 on pages 72 to 86 townsend road
reserve tory
tori there yeah she's name's there
you're there hi
hi good evening mr chair and good
evening board members
uh i'll take the reporters read but just
to introduce it a little and the purpose
of the report is to request approval for
staff to carry out consultation on the
proposed concept plan for townsend
road reserve which as you know is in
within townsend fields subdivision
consultation would be carried out with
residents
in the surrounding area of the reserve
and also um
not noted in the report but it would be
taken back to the students
at to tomato school who participate
participated in the initial
brainstorming session that we held
to show them the same consultation
information
following consultation we'd bring the
feedback back to you
to
note the feedback that we got and also
to show you the proposed concept plan
for approval
i'd be happy to take
any questions if you have some
that's good that's a good process thanks
to our questions
anyone got a question
everyone's head down and looking very
busy so
we have a recommendation in front of us
as someone prepared to indicate moving
the recommendation
you're all here thanks paul segmented by
robbie do you paul do you wish to speak
to it
no i think it's important a new
subdivisionary we need a play area for
the um
the future
um
adults of the community and that it's
important for um children to have that
sort of area put aside for them
thank you robbie no well done paul by
green tiny
oh good you're very hard to see robbie
we just see your eyes hello
that's better right any anyone else wish
to um add anything
that maybe be involved the waimaku
access group be involved to make sure
it's suitable for people with
disabilities perhaps
yes definitely yes we'll take it through
the accessibility group and um get get
their input through the whole process
anyone else wish to
duncan i only passed the commentary i
think it's
you've done a very good job and i'll
show that see the photo there you
consulting with the younger people of
our district um one day they'll be rate
payers so i think the issue of
consulting right at that early age um
does put the council in a good state
thank you thank you
thank you appreciate that
i don't think you've got anything to
reply to paul so i'll put that all those
in favor please say aye or indicate i a
thumbs up against
carried
item 6.7
uh wrangler community boards
discretionary grant tia do you wish to
or would you introduce this please
yes mr chairperson do you want to take
them separately or do i introduce one of
them
maybe we will take them separately
because some are straightforward and
some might be slightly
different so
but you speak to them all in one and
then we'll just put the question
separately
thank you for you mr jefferson we have
three applications for grant funding one
is from the rangiora cricket club
for
496 dollars for buying new
cricket balls for match games they will
then use the old balls just for practice
then we have an application for
eight hundred dollars
for the
um
muscular dystrophy association
and this is for the rengu aura group
although i want to
just
draw members attention to the fact that
they in their application they stated
that the funding would be um
would reduce the burden to cover wider
operational
funds such as wages
and um in terms of the criteria the
board grants should not be actually used
for wages so it is actually my
suggestion that we just lay this
application on the table until i get
more information from them
on exactly what they want to use the
funding for
on that so i'd interrupt you if you're
going back to them if the board decide
to land on the table and follow your
advice
i i think might clear we would
like to help them if they had anything
for the participants that we can assist
that meets them and what they're doing
you know what i'm saying just yes give
them the option to come back to us if
the board's happy we'll come back thank
you
and then the third one is for the cast
district historical record society they
actually want to copy and sell a booklet
that they own the copyrights for
on the
um
grand sorry on the motorcycle grand prix
races that was held in cast
and um yeah they asking for the cost of
the cutting and the binding of those
booklets and that is
665 dollars
i'm happy to answer any questions if i
can questions of tia
all right we'll deal with them one at a
time uh if someone's prepared to move a
and
the b or c for the cricket
they're asking for 496 dollars i'm happy
to move that particular one
move by sarah seconded by
jason
any discussion
no
all right i'll put that all those in
favor please say i
will indicate i
against
no
carried right the next one
tia suggests and i actually agree with
her rather than just say no because well
800 to start with one issue
but if we lay it on the table
uh if you're
mine too that requires a motion of
course and tear right to them to clarify
whether they can meet the criteria and
we can make a grant to help individuals
or the group
here in rangiora is is everyone happy
with that approach or do you just want
to say no or say yes
some i'm happy to have it on the table
paul
yeah um i agree with you exactly jim so
i'd like to move the motion that we um
allowed on the table but we inform them
of our views to um seeing how we can
help them right thank you we're second
for that it's a procedural motion move
sarah a second about sarah so i'm about
to put that all those in favor please
say all right hi all right anyone
opposed claire carried now we move on to
the third one which is the cast and
historical record society
i've got a question on that one mr chair
yes
um my understanding from reading the
application and talking to one of the
members is that this is only the part
they're asking for is only for the
scanning of this historic book to keep
it safe that the
the
project does intend to print books but
they're already asking us
for the 665
to scan the booklet i understand that
and there is nothing uh the board has
the ability if it wants to to offer this
full 665 that's up to the board 500 is
our normal guideline but in the case of
something like this it's quite
appropriate to would make whatever
decision you want so someone got a
suggestion to move something here i'm
happy to test the meeting with 665 mr
chip thank you kirsten if we're second
for that i will duncan has seconded it
we should speak to it
just very very briefly the the
volunteers at the cusp museum do amazing
amount of work this booklet it will
deteriorate if it's not scanned so it's
really important to preserve the history
of our area and they have a very active
committee who is very good at promoting
so i'm sure that the overall project
will go ahead
duncan
i can only follow what kirsten has said
but
members who haven't been to the cast
museum i would encourage them to do so
so well it's a very small building it's
full of action so it is actually amazing
and um there's a lot of history in that
building and i just point out it it's
totally consistent what we did with the
ring you were a historical society
early records about three or four years
ago so
right anyone else wish to
speak
nothing to reply to so would you please
indicate your support all those in favor
may against
declare it carried
right correspondence uh is there we need
a motion to receive it
someone forget to move that
um
you skipped one sorry
what have i skipped
6.8
i'll come back to that then
all right i put a line through before
you know we'll deal with the
correspondence while i'm there and pop
back
some paid to move but we received the
correspondence moved by kirsten seconded
by
morris i'll put that all those in favor
please say aye the country carried or
indication we'll get there
we'll pop back 6.8 ratification of the
ashley community board submission sets
to
retrospectively uh both the council and
the ecan
so someone prepared to move that
well i'll move it if i second it
now a second and second it
put that all those in favor please say i
country carried
chairperson's report on page 157
i'll move it duncan will second it
9.1 that matters right through there to
9.6
and then we have the public excluded
report which
is included in the recommendation that
someone prepared to move that we receive
the information and receive the public
excluded and it remain public excluded
segmented by jason i'll put that all
those in favor please say all right
i can't
carry right
we'll start down there
where will we start we'll start with
paul
information exchange
yeah well i've been quite busy and fed
her
as per last month we've been um having a
a lot of sessions on the gravel and
stronger roads around um waimakariri and
um
it's um
been agreed by the staff and um
they are working quite hard now looking
at um re-metalling the um the gravel
roads around the area up to a better
standard
and
the good thing is we may have a
that new acolyte roading stuff they put
on has been been quite good and
successful
and that's has to be transferred from
way down by oxford up to the um forestry
for example
and
with a bit of luck we may have found a
seam of
that same similar stuff and
the forestry um people have found it
there so we we might have a better
access to um a cheaper or be a lot
cheaper in the cartridge anyway um to
get it for our rural gravel roads so
that's looking quite promising
um
we've been pushing to get uh
when a road gets re-mettled
um that it gets rolled at the same time
which is pretty important because
sometimes uh
just spreading the um
the new top course on top of it and
we're getting a bit of flood and it's
getting washed away pretty quickly so
um by rolling it in and um
maybe even wetting it when we're rolling
it then we'll be a bit more successful
um
process set up
what has it got there
um
yeah we've i've also been concentrating
on a lot of the drainage matters and um
the staff have been um
getting um
better at um
looking after the drains by getting
cleaned we have got a bit of a problem
with the covert because um it's hard
getting crews
out there now because a lot of them are
away with um covered and everything so
um and there's a lot of drains and we're
coming up to the winter which is very
important so um
so that's sort of um a bit of a priority
for the council at the moment um
on the water side
you've probably heard a wee bit of
scenarios about the um asbestos pipes
around
um that's a wee bit of a um cloak and
dagger situation on that because
the asbestos um
fiber like pipes where i've been using
is actually quite safe in health and
from the advice all the water people
have had it only creates a problem if
it's not wet
and if the um water pipes are they're
always wet so um
it's not really a um a problem at all
we've had them for years to be on the
safe side they are all on the
replacement schedule for waimekaroo to
have the pipes replaced as they um
the ageism are coming up to the um
age of replacing me anyway so um that is
on the cards for getting
them replaced
so um that's about it for me
andy
you unmute
you're still muted
still muted
yep i think you're there
can
no you're still muted
can't hear you
so while you work that out uh should we
just go on to joan in the meantime
thank you um yes we've been really
really busy at council
um this last month we've had um the
autism risk meeting which i chair we've
had meetings with ecan with regard to
their annual plan
um we've had meetings of also part of
the banker new zealand divestment
um committee which um we have we're
underway with which i think i reported
last time airfield advisory group we've
had a meeting with them
and there are security cameras are in
place now
so that's good
uh utilities and roading meeting
we've had um briefings on the annual
plan
and um lots of briefings that we've had
big day yesterday at council
uh a meeting with um local um
[Music]
uh
a greater christchurch partnership
briefings on special
um
and transport um heading out to 2030
2050 so
that's um there's been yeah it's been it
was a big day yesterday a long day um
zooming is pretty tough
you know eight hours assuming is that
takes it out of you a bit
um
futures for local governments we've been
discussing that um
and uh
uh what have i got here
um
yes we've had council meetings with
tentative
uh something on
development oh that's right we had a
meeting with tamari tao on um
um
development contributions so was nice
meeting there
um business promotions we've had a
meeting there um so hopefully with town
centres that we might be able to move
forward with hosting some events this
year in the future because nothing's
been happening we're very mindful of um
[Music]
of uh retail being down but we're hoping
to promote
um the town centres and people to shop
locally so
um let's hope that and i did hear today
that um business is picking up a little
bit people are starting to get out a bit
more now so let's hope that there's an
ongoing situation so there we go it's
been very busy
joan you mentioned the local government
reform is there anything you can tell us
that's in the public arena about what
direction it's going or are you still
at a confidential stage on that
oh there's there's lots
it's um
yeah there's just so much um happening
it's
not really not at the moment
um
i think it's still in a process
and
lots
there's still lots of discussion
and um all will be revealed i think down
the track yeah
that's that's quite complicated and
complex
okay andy are you back there yet or are
you
not
anybody hear me yes
really yeah yeah really
no no you've just muted yourself now
you've unmuted
no you're gone again you you you muted
yourself a moment ago we saw the little
icon come up can you hear me yes
okay i'm not going to touch anything is
it still working yes my goodness
clearly i should um i should get some
more
this is terrible um i've been very busy
with paul looking at the roads um
they
uh there's been a lot of activity uh on
the community pages i've been talking to
a number of people that are still very
unhappy
so
it is really encouraging that we're
getting some progress
um
so uh yeah that's
that's about
all i've been up to really it's gravel
roads
well you're doing a good job there
because it's an important issue for our
rural communities so i think thank
thanks
there
sarah
um it's been quieter for me because i
had a rough ride with covert and that
took up a few weeks in my time but we're
all good now
um but i attended the rengarus squadron
88 emerald general meeting the last week
on thursday night
my son is a
as a member there and it was uh meet and
greet the parents and meet the members
on the board
um so that was really good to hear what
they've been up to
and where they're heading and they made
specific mention
of the support of the waimakariri
council and in particular they did
mention
council award they said you've done a
great job
and
um
uh in the mir as well so they were very
pleased good things to say
um other than that
um there's just so much
theft in our area i mean i'm on the
northwest side of rangiora
um you know if you leave something on
the backseat of your car
i wouldn't do it just maybe check before
you
lock your car um it's quite sad actually
what's going on but it is what it is so
just
yeah watch out for things like that too
much of it going on
but that's all thank you
thank you sir morris
you're the mrs yes yeah just i've got
nothing to report jim all right thank
you jason
this month been a bit busy at work with
covert and whatnot
right
okay monique
um just a request from the member of the
public for maybe some more seating and
dudley in the north park and the north
part of dudley park
perhaps in the sun and that same person
was suggesting they could even put some
money toward it so i don't know where
perhaps i pass that on to green space or
something i'll talk to t well green's
face is sitting down the bottom
listening the ground
but tia talk to tia and she'll follow
that up for you
all right
murray
yes well i um
went along at your advice and spoke to
the council staff and the next day they
fixed the pothole outside the pharmacy
but it wasn't really a pothole it was
two metres long and it was a seal
failure
in the process of that after a while
some of the council staff came along and
started talking about replacing the
footpaths
and the greg of the ragura pharmacy rang
me this morning and said there's
everybody down there doing a lot of work
so i went down had a look than they were
they had it all dug up they had it all
fenced off and they were handling it
very well actually had people
a person on the entrance to the durham
health and a person on the entrance to
regular pharmacy guiding elderly people
in and out and making sure they didn't
get the trouble i thought that was very
good
i was accosted by an elderly gentleman
who was there god knows where it came
from he was jumping up and down about
the amount of money that
the council was spending on the footpath
and wasn't necessary etc but i pointed
out to him that it had the old dish
um
like we talked about one day on the
phone which the street cleaners couldn't
manage and in the course of the work
they're actually altering the curb to
the new profiles so they'll be able to
clean it machine clean it from there on
so i actually think it was a good job
and he was quite satisfied that
explanation he went away in the finish
and also
adding to that i went to ranger farming
family doctors about something else and
i got bombarded with questions about the
health hub
and it appears that
like canterbury health is no longer
they're doing the demolition but they're
not going to do the reconstruction
that's going to be done by health fleet
south
and family doctors said they weren't
happy with the pains i'd seen and i said
where are they they couldn't show them
to me
so i still don't know and i really think
we all see these plans somehow or
another somewhere along the line
but there's no plans being given to
anybody and the other thing is the
demolition they removed the asbestos and
they didn't do anything about
demolishing the old hospital for a long
time so i
emailed dan gordon and dan rang
canterbury health and he got it
activated again and up there but they're
moving very slowly they are demolishing
the building
i think we need to keep an eye on that
all right thanks thanks murray that's
good robbie
robbie
i'm getting there jim good that's right
thank you um so yeah just jason
mentioned the challenges of of covert um
there's been significant challenges in
my portfolio as well as far as waste is
concerned uh good work to kitty menis
and our contractor to keep the transfer
station
and collections operating uh
certainly uh we're looking at uh
knocking green waste on the head a
couple of weeks ago because we were
lacking a load of drivers
but nevertheless hopefully we're over
that that hell and we're not going to be
faced with that challenge
again
the i don't know if you're aware but
that dudley paul had to close early uh
last night again due to challenges as
far as coverts concerned
uh most of you are aware my partner
jessica works at the the pool um she got
pulled in to do a 10 hour shift uh today
opening the pole at 20 to 6 this morning
so the lifeguards could get in there
and she got home just just on six
tonight so
um covert is certainly still here and
present and will be presenting um issues
as far as again with waste um the cape
valley joint committee we met
um
mainly discussed the the soi and and
there's a new buyer
as far as the other 50 percent uh
shareholding is is concerned that's
still subject to approval um so i won't
go into too much detail as far as that
is concerned with regard to the joint
standing committee on on waste
as most of you are aware we have a
budget for waste minimisation projects
again due to the issues of covered
a lot of that wasn't tapped in the last
financial year
so the decisions been
made to pretty much hold over the funds
having said that there was a bit of a
misunderstanding amongst member councils
as well
waimakariri still holds on to its share
it's just that we don't spend it so each
individual council holds on to the share
the issue with one of the big issues is
we're looking at a more regional
approach approach to waste minimization
and we've invited environment canterbury
to
consider going partners in a regional
position as far as uh regional
minimization is concerned
i'm not sure the reasons why but it
hasn't seemed to have made environment
canterbury's
meetings as as yet which is a bit of
frustration to me as we come to because
this was something i was quite hot on at
the start of the term and here we are
still discussing it towards the end of
the term
um
with the the levy and increasing as it
is and more money becoming available
it's imperative that a bigger picture is
taken into
consideration as far as regional and
and even potentially further
minimization practices are concerned
um something that has read its a nasty
head over the last couple of days which
you should be aware of
is with regard to the hockey turf
we have an issue which is probably being
compounded by the stadium
construction
in that
it is filling up with debris
there is a health and safety issue as
far as that is concerned
there's been a series of emails between
various staff
and others
as to potential fixes
one of them is the introduction of a
machine from america with a three
hundred thousand dollar price tag
so that sort of thing you you need to
look um
at partnerships because there are other
hockey turfs in canterbury
um
so hopefully staff will put their heads
together and come up with a solution
because we run the risk of of losing
premier games
at the pristine hockey turf that we have
due to health and safety issues and
players slipping over because they can't
get the traction required
so yeah and joan mentioned it's but it's
been a busy period a lot of it's going
on behind the scenes and i've gotta i'll
publicly express my absolute frustration
uh with regard to central government
because by god they're making things
very very very hard for local bodies at
the at the moment and tracy's team
made a presentation on that in a
briefing yesterday just emphasized to me
how difficult it is
working with this wellington bureaucracy
so that's it from me thank you
robbie just on the surface of the hockey
turf
uh is that because uh it's getting
embedded in the false grass or whatever
you call it and getting underneath or is
it
because i know that
people with
tennis courts are the same sort of thing
there is some machine you can now get or
hire it's quite expensive but we'll suck
them clean
so i just uh that's some tennis courts
have had that done
yeah no look star staff are working on
it because we don't want to lose that
premier grade coming coming out here
we've got competition from selwyn uh now
with with their new turf
so we don't want to lose um those teams
coming out here
it is a benefit to waimakariri in so
many ways
and
yeah there's various options being
discussed but at the moment the front
runner is actually people getting on
there with water blasters
um but you know that involves people and
time and uh
look i'm trusting the staff to get to
get over this um
i just mentioned it in case it was
useful that was all right moving on
kirsten
oh thank you mr chair and
joan mentioned the annual plan with um
coverts sort of not still being out of
the woods with it yet we are going to
have to do that by zoom this year so
that's going to be a little bit more
challenging for the the hearings um but
it has worked very well in the past with
being able to do so um if we do need to
hold some in person they have been
discussing it but the risks of staff and
our members at the current time was
deemed a bit too high to have those
hearings in person so they will be
zoomed this year um scooters we've
extended the trial for another year with
the scooters we actually had a very
successful trials to date with very few
complaints only 61 complaints over the
whole trial
um and
they are keeping the
no go zone in the high street however at
the moment over the next year
and they have released the no-go zone
from
across the pegasus roundabout however at
the request of residence there so you
can travel on scooter from rangira to
pegasus
um
the most important issue that's been
occupying my time recently has been the
recent proliferation of boy races in the
cust area
we've had several instances of it over
the last month one where
cars were actually doing
uh burnouts for three to four hours in
the middle of the night on tram and tram
road and
um early's road corner which is actually
in the ohoka
oxford ohoka ward but only just down the
road and we had a
bad
experience with driving taking out a
power pole and
hundreds of households lost power for
about four hours out here um and we've
had very bad
on davis early's road and
terrace road we've had we've got black
tire marks and rip tires in fact it
looked so bad it looked like that a
flock of crows had been decimated on the
road
um and then we had a funeral at the cass
community centre that unfortunately was
not the family but some of the members
who attended got out of hand and they
decided to honor their friend they would
do burn ups up and down
mill road and in front of the community
center so at the moment the cass
community centre has black marks all
over the road in front of it that's very
unsightly we're concerned that it will
proliferate this behavior even more
we're in discussions with the police
because we've had some complaints from
residents that police are not responding
to the and they're just too too
stretched cast is covered by the oxford
police station and there is only two
policemen and they're not always both on
duty so we um are actually going to
initiate a discussion on rural policing
um in this area because of the fact that
we we've suddenly become known as the
place to go where there's no police
uh so that's going to be
and i've kept the cheerfully employed
kitchen informed on that as well but
it's of major concern to our residents
some are talking about taking the law
into their own hands um most are quite
distressed with all the black marks
right outside their community center and
there doesn't seem to be a particularly
easy way forward
thank you for that kirsten and just on
the boy races and the rubber look it's
everywhere now it's urban eye it's just
this round rangiora as well it's
happening everywhere so i hope the
council talked firmly to the police
because they need to actually have an
operation out here i suspect
like i think we do and christchurch has
had a very successful operation where
they've started to impound some cars um
and we've seen that on the police sites
so it's probably time they turn their
attention i think perhaps we are getting
the people from christchurch who are
deciding we're an easy mark i think so
robbie do you want to comment yeah well
yeah i i passed on because i saw
kirsten's thing i passed on to pierre i
don't know if he related on but
um over the last uh couple of three
weeks i've impounded two cars and it
came very close to a third
um so you know we
we do the best we can
video is really good if we can get video
but certainly i wouldn't want citizens
putting themselves at risk taking that
um
but yeah we do the best we can and as i
say two cars and very close to a third
she got a six hundred dollar
infringement instead
for her boy racer activity she wasn't as
bad as the other two
um so i decided not to impound her car
i i think robbie no one is blaming the
police we just know that the resources
are very very stretched and
i think also the other thing is that we
need to publicize some of these
activities in a so that people can see
there are consequences i certainly had
feedback from my daughter at high school
where boys were talking in a group and
said that there's just no police so it's
easy um so we need to get the word
around that there are police around that
there are
cars being impounded and it might
actually alter the behaviour
thank you both right duncan
um
i suppose it's been the common thread on
the north shore this year this month has
been ship gravel roads and look i think
paul and andy for their work um the
grader was spotted at quarter past five
on a friday afternoon so one would
presume that the heat was on um
but you know jokes aside um hayden rhodo
cooking for example um there is a an
issue with drainage as far as layering
water into some of these roadways
which obviously is stripping a fair bit
of shingle out so
the two go hand in hand to a certain
extent so thanks for that work
um and yes we've had our share of
complaints as well um and also just the
upgrade the lobin reserve is having an
internal paint job
and uh the heaters are being upgraded so
there's a bit of a
splash on inside the building so
hopefully things will be greatly
improved thank you
thank you right thank you thank you all
for
for that i thought
oh cool
just just to comment on your drainage
beside the roads um the staff have been
informed about that and they're actually
looking at cutting some channels on some
of the travel roads when they ride
equipment's here to get rid of some that
um water runoff as well
so it's um that they are looking at that
as well
thank you thank you thank you paul uh
tia i think we'll take the anzac day uh
service now if you like
where's tia yeah i am thank you mr chair
um
due to the fact that some of the covert
restrictions has actually been lifted
the
rsi has agreed that there will be some
anzac services
this year
um and the board you can sorry can i
just get it in front of me the board
usually uh
lays reefs at various places
on on the 25th
and we therefore just need to know if
the board will be sending
representatives
to um we've got cast at nine
right dirty let's deal with casters
anyone
able to represent the board and lay a
wreath at custer 9 30.
i can i am but anyone else
kirsten
does anyone go with her
all right kirsten will do that here
there that's that's good uh
then we have
the rangiora high school all over
remember it's also at 9 30.
all right we've got a board member that
can go to the
high school
and lay a wreath there on behalf of the
board
last one all right duncan will do that
that's good thank you duncan and who
would like to represent the board at the
rangiora at cenotaph i'm not sure where
they're marching or what they're doing
we don't know do we tell you what
they're what they're planning but
that'll be at 11 o'clock i presume
that's 11 30 and there's no parade it's
just the laying of the reefs
well i'm happy to do that then if no one
else wants to
all right
duncan will come with me on that so that
that'll be good
for those now you will see the wreaths
will be delivered
uh
all right no that's good everyone happy
with that
okay
item 11 is consultation except for your
information item 12
uh and is just to tell you where we're
at on the discretionary grant and the
general landscape
funds just for information
no media items no questions no urgent
general business so that brings us to an
end to the formal meeting part can i ask
one question yeah duncan did my nick
raise a hand regarding the cenotaph or
do you want to be involved
so i can't hear you
all right we can talk about it yeah okay
so
right now we're moving into the work
workshop and we've got um bell grove
development frontage along kittenburg
avenue
[Music]
you